[MUSIC PLAYING]
AJA HAMMERLY: Hello, and
welcome to episode number
205 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Aja.
And I am here with
my colleague, Brian.
Hey, Brian.
BRIAN DORSEY: Hello, Aja.
AJA HAMMERLY: So later
today we have an interview
with two of our
colleagues, Jez and Nathen.
That is awesome.
They're going to teach
us all about the DevOps.
And what's our question of the
week about this week, Brian?
BRIAN DORSEY: It is, what
actually is the Cloud SQL
proxy?
And why does one even
want such a thing?
AJA HAMMERLY: Yes, we
will get to that later.
But first, my favorite part
of the podcast every week,
cool thing of the week.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN DORSEY: Yay!
AJA HAMMERLY: First,
the cool thing
is the Cloud Next
London just happened.
And I was there.
And it was cool.
It was really high energy.
And there was lots
of stuff announced.
And everyone was just an
absolute delight to talk to.
I got to answer and ask a
lot of really cool questions.
People had questions for
the panel that I ran.
But Brian actually
has spent more time
looking over the entire list
of stuff that was announced.
So Brian, do you want to
talk a little bit about what
you noticed?
BRIAN DORSEY: Sure,
I got all this
from kind of a wrap-up
blog post that we made.
So it's worth checking out.
It's a wrap key announcements
from Next 19 UK.
And we're going to have a link
to that in the show notes.
But big picture, I thought,
there's a lot of small things.
And it feels like the
theme was bringing
Cloud and your on-premise
data centers closer together.
So along those lines, things
about bringing existing IP
addresses that you
may have and not
be able to change
configuration around,
you can actually bring those to
GCP and make them part of GCP.
You can rent bare
metal machines, kind of
like in racks that are
network-wise and physically
very close to Google
interconnects.
If you need to run something
you have complete control
over, but also really fast pipe,
some more network monitoring.
Things are on hybrid apps,
migration tools for migrating
existing machines to Cloud
VMs or into containers
on Kubernetes and what have you.
And Cloud Run for
Anthos was announced--
so a bunch of stuff in that
theme of connecting things.
And then I also wanted to
highlight around the AI ML
stuff.
I'm definitely no
expert in this space,
but it seems like one of
the ongoing challenges
is just understanding
the models.
And the team has
done a ton of work
under the umbrella
of explainable AI.
It's really worth
checking out if you're
involved in that space at all.
And, Aja, my question for
you is, while you were there,
did you get tea?
AJA HAMMERLY: I did get tea.
I had tea with some of
the Googlers the day
before the conference.
And it was amazing.
It was so good.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh,
that is fantastic.
I was in Denver last week
and had afternoon tea,
but it was not in London,
so a little bit jealous.
What's your cool
thing of the week?
AJA HAMMERLY: My cool
thing of the week, one
of our former colleagues who
is now working on Open Source
at Google, Julia,
pointed me at a blog post
that talks about how you
can take GraphViz diagrams
and using an extension
make them look hand drawn.
And I've done a bunch of stuff
with GraphViz over the years.
And my most recent
thing was a blog post
I did on taking Cloud bill files
and showing the dependencies
using GraphViz by
creating a DOT file
that I did for Mark
McDowell, the former lead
host of the podcast.
And now I can make them
look like I hand drew them.
And for someone
who does not draw
straight lines without a ruler
very well, this is awesome.
So there'll be a
link in the show
notes to this
particular blog post
from showing how to do this.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh,
that's super cool.
I love, love, love that.
In fact, just this
weekend I noticed
in Matplotlib, this
graphing library for Python,
it has a mode to enable XKCD
comic style sketchy graphs
in that same theme.
AJA HAMMERLY: I love the
fact that we have made things
to make our digitally generated
things look like they were not
digitally generated.
We have come full circle.
It's awesome.
BRIAN DORSEY: Let's bring
a little more humanity
into all the things.
On that note, let's switch to
the conversation with Nathen
and Jez about DevOps.
OK, so super excited to have
both Nathen and Jez here today.
Can I ask you each to
introduce yourself quickly
and your connection at DevOps?
So we'll start with Nathen.
NATHEN HARVEY: Great, hi,
my name is Nathen Harvey.
And I am a developer advocate
here at Google Cloud.
And the area where I focus is
on the DevOps and SRE community.
So what's my
background with DevOps?
I've been sort of circling in
and around the DevOps community
for, I don't know,
eight or nine years.
And I used to be a DevOp.
I don't believe you can be a
DevOp, but I used to be one.
So what does that mean?
It means that I used to be
responsible for managing
operations at an
online retailer.
And we would build, deploy,
manage applications.
I helped manage
the infrastructure.
We were moving from the
data center into the cloud.
And then eventually
I left that job
and became a developer
advocate or community organizer
and have been spending the
last eight years in that space.
BRIAN DORSEY: Excellent.
JEZ HUMBLE: I am also
working in dev rel
as a developer advocate.
My connection to DevOps
is that I co-authored
a book called "Continuous
Delivery," which came out
around the same time that the
DevOps movement was really
starting to be a
thing, to the extent
that we actually got
DevOps into the book.
And it was the
first published book
that actually mentions DevOps,
I think, as far as I know.
I'm also co-author of
the "DevOps Handbook"
and of "Accelerate," which
is a book based on a research
program that myself and
Dr. Nicole Forsgren, who's
also at Google, along with
a bunch of other folks,
including the people at
Puppet, have been working on
for the last six
years, which looks
at how to measure
software delivery
performance, the
factors that impact it,
and why it's important.
A whole bunch of
that research is up
at Cloud.Google.com/devops,
along with the last six years
of state of DevOps reports.
BRIAN DORSEY: So we're
going to kick this off
with the easy question.
What is DevOps?
JEZ HUMBLE: Well, the
first thing to say
is that there is no
definition of DevOps.
And that's on purpose.
The people who really,
I guess we can say
are the founders of
the movement, which
is Patrick Debois
and Andrey Schaefer,
they deliberately
didn't want there
to be a definition of DevOps.
They didn't want there
to be a manifesto.
They didn't want
any of that stuff
because they had seen
what had happened
to the Agile movement, where
it basically got taken over
by a whole bunch of people
and deployed in order to make
money and sell people stuff
and all those kind of things.
They're like, we're
not doing that.
We want this to be I
guess what today we'd
call a community of
practice, basically,
of people who are
trying to get better
at building and operating
distributed systems at scale
that were secure and reliable.
And that's, when I'm
asked to define it,
that's how I normally define it.
It's a community
of practice trying
to solve a particular
problem, which
is how do we build large
scale distributed systems
that are secure and resilient?
However, everyone
wants a definition.
We have a definition at
Cloud.Google.com/devops.
It's one we made
up by ourselves.
And it says, "DevOps
is an organization
and cultural movement that aims
to increase software delivery
velocity, improve service
reliability, and build share
ownership among software
stakeholders," which
is as good as any, I think.
I don't hate.
I quite like it.
Nathen, you must have
thoughts on this.
NATHEN HARVEY: Sure, I have at
least three other definitions
that I'll run you
through right now.
That's not actually true.
I'm not going to run you
through three other definitions.
But I always like to, when
I'm asked to define DevOps,
I, for better or
worse, just like
to become a little
bit of a historian
and say, well, how did that
word actually come into being?
And there are kind of two almost
simultaneous origin stories.
One is that John Allspaw
and Paul Hammond gave a talk
at Velocity, and the
talk was titled something
like 10 Deploys a Day.
And there was a slide in
that talk that on one side
had Dev, on the other side
had Ops, and in the middle
had a heart.
So that's one part of the
origin story of the term DevOps.
The other part is that an
Agile conference there was
a Birds of a Feather session.
And I think it was Andrew
Clay Schaefer proposed
a topic at that Birds
of a Feather session
called Agile infrastructure.
And then he realized that no
one at the Agile conference
was going to show up for that,
so he skipped his own Birds
of a Feather session.
And Patrick Debois did show up.
So eventually they met.
And then Patrick
started this whole--
like coined the term DevOps by
starting a conference called
DevOps Days.
But the interesting
thing at that time,
I think the reason
that it was called
DevOps was because
we kind of recognized
this wall of confusion
between dev and ops.
And the way that I
always talk about it is,
it's about how we
align those incentives.
So we tell developers,
your job is
to build features and
make the customer happy.
And then we turn to
operations and we say,
your job is to keep
the system stable.
And so what does that do?
That turns the developers
into push, push, push,
and the operators into no, stop.
Because to keep the system
stable, what I will do
is accept no changes
in the system.
And that became a real problem.
So DevOps was born
from how do we actually
stop this throwing stuff
over the wall of confusion
from dev to ops but instead
get dev and ops to realize
that what they're both here to
do is focus on the customer.
And so today, and why DevOps
is this cultural movement,
I really look at it as,
this is how we actually
get IT to align to the
business and understand,
what is the business objective?
And so I think DevOps
is a terrible word.
JEZ HUMBLE: So one interesting
historical footnote
to that is we just had
the very last Velocity
conference in Berlin this year.
In as much as one book
ended this movement
was the first Velocity
conference in 2009.
We just finished it off.
And of course, that was
co-founded by John Allspaw
and Steve Souders of Google.
AJA HAMMERLY: Speaking
of conferences,
the DevOps Days conference
recently celebrated
its 10-year anniversary.
And I am ashamed to admit that
I remember the first DevOps
Days in Seattle happening and
being very confused as to what
that was.
What's a DevOps Days?
NATHEN HARVEY: That is
a great question, Aja.
So a DevOps Days,
as you mentioned,
it's celebrated its
10-year anniversary.
There's a really
interesting thing--
I think first we'll just start
with the format of a DevOps
Days.
So a DevOps Days is a
locally organized conference,
which is why there have
been many in Seattle.
There have been many
in Washington, DC.
All over the world these
conferences happen.
But the key behind a
DevOps Days conference
is really to celebrate
the idea of bringing
a cross-functional
group of humans
together to collaborate on
what are the things that
are top of mind around
how do you do IT better,
how do you DevOp, how do you
align better with the business
strategy, what are
the cultural changes
that you need to bring
into your organization?
And in order to really help
with that collaboration,
a typical DevOps Days
includes about half
pre-determined content, so talks
from presenters that are maybe
keynotes or 30-minute
talks, and then also
some ignite talks, which
are nice five-minute talks--
inspire us, but keep it short.
But the other half
of the conference
is where it gets really,
really interesting.
The conference
organizers kind of
turn it over the
conference to the attendees
of that conference.
And it's typically done through
a process called open spaces.
And in open spaces, every
participant at the conference
is invited to propose
a talk or propose
a topic, a topic that they
are interested in learning
more about, something
that they want to share.
And the only rule is you
have to be passionate enough
about that topic to
start a conversation.
From there, the
participants self-organize
into small discussion
groups and talk
about each one of those topics.
And so the idea
behind it is really
that practitioners, the people
that are out there making
these changes within
their organizations,
are sharing with one
another exactly what they're
doing, where they're running
into friction, how they're
overcoming that friction.
And it's a really
great conference series
to help you connect with
your local community
and drive the practice of DevOps
and the principles of DevOps
forward within
your organization.
AJA HAMMERLY: OK, I
think I get it now.
You have done a good sales pitch
for the DevOps Days conference
series.
NATHEN HARVEY: All right.
One of the other interesting
things I think about it is it's
truly locally organized.
So in 2019, I think
there were 80 DevOps
Days that happened globally.
Yeah, I see that
look on your face.
None of the podcast listeners
can see that look on your face,
but it is one of shock.
AJA HAMMERLY: I am making
a giant shock face.
NATHEN HARVEY: Indeed.
And the way that
works is each one
is locally organized by a
local group of volunteers.
There is a global organizing
committee, of which
I happen to be a part of.
But our role as the
global organizers
is really to provide some
of the infrastructure,
like the website, some coaching
on what should your agenda look
like, and some guidance on that.
But each one is
locally organized,
operated, and executed.
BRIAN DORSEY: Sweet.
OK, since we're mining
things other people said.
There was this mention
of the Accelerate
State of DevOps report.
And that sounds
important and big.
And you mentioned
research-based.
So I'm curious,
what is this thing?
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah, so
State of DevOps reports
kind of started off as a
kind of industry report
produced by Puppet Labs,
as it was back in the day.
And the very first time, I think
I was involved in year two,
and when we were
presenting after year two,
someone walked up to
one of the organizers
at a Puppet conference
was like, hey, you know
that you're doing it wrong.
And the people there were
like, oh, that's interesting.
And who are you?
And this person was like,
well, I'm Dr. Nicole Forsgren.
I am a researcher at Utah
State University, a professor
at Utah State University
who does stuff
on systems administration.
I do research on
systems administration
amongst other things
and I'm a statistician.
And this person was smart
enough to say, well,
maybe you should come and
talk to the people who do it
and be involved in that.
And so in year
three, 2014, Nicole
joined us and injected basically
statistical and methodological
rigor into it.
And so it ended up being this
research-driven, academically
rigorous program
looking into how
you measure software delivery
performance, the impacts
of that, the things that impact
software delivery performance.
And so over the last six
years, we've built up,
I think, more than 30,000
data points of observations
by this point, from all
different kinds of companies,
of all different
domains and sizes.
And we have actually
a pretty good idea
of how you get better at
doing software delivery.
And we have data and
research that makes
that useful and applicable.
AJA HAMMERLY: But what
does the research show?
JEZ HUMBLE: That's
a great question.
We actually have
what we lovingly
refer to as the BFD, or the
Big and Fulsome Diagram,
which is currently in the
process of being revised.
And podcast users might
not be able to see this,
but I'm holding it up.
AJA HAMMERLY: It's huge.
JEZ HUMBLE: It's a big piece
of paper with lots of arrows,
and boxes, and words.
AJA HAMMERLY: It
looks like scary UML.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yes.
And the reason
that I have this is
because we're revising it to
include the 2019 findings.
And some poor
person at Google is
going to be tasked
with turning this
into something kind of
beautiful and friendly
that you can print out
and put above your desk,
or frame and hang above
your bed for that matter
if that's what does it for you.
And I mean, broadly
speaking, what
it does is it shows you what
helps you get better software
delivery performance.
And there's
basically four groups
of things, a whole bunch
of technical practices
that we lovingly call
continuous delivery,
obviously because
that was me, so things
like continuous testing, at
least a couple of architecture,
building security into the
software delivery process,
deployment automation
trunk-based development,
and a bunch of other things.
Some lean management practices
like managing work in process,
limiting work in process,
visual management
feedback from production.
Some lean product
development practices
like working in small
batches and making
the flow work visible.
And a whole bunch
of cultural stuff
like, for example,
retrospectives or postmortems,
creating autonomous
teams and so forth.
And we show that all those
things impact software delivery
performance.
Some of them also lead
to less burned out teams,
and less deployment
pain, and less rework.
Some of them increase
job satisfaction.
Software delivery
performance, in turn,
increases organizational
performance.
So we know that getting
better at software delivery
makes your organization
more effective, as well.
So it basically says, well, if
you want to get better at this,
here are all the things that you
need to do to get better at it.
AJA HAMMERLY: Sounds
like I should read more
than the first 10 pages.
JEZ HUMBLE: There's a lot.
It's definitely a rabbit hole
that you can dive into and get
very deep into.
AJA HAMMERLY: I will say that
the parts of it I've read
have been incredibly
insightful and have
made me think about
not just the operations
side, but the software
in general and cultures
around software teams
in a very different way.
JEZ HUMBLE: Great.
Thank you.
And we've drawn on
Google's research as well.
And one of the things
that Google's famous for
is Project Aristotle,
the research
on how to build high
performing teams at Google.
We've been able to
replicate that research.
This year we looked at
code maintainability
using stuff from Google's
internal programs.
So a lot of it actually
is replicated stuff
that has been found in Google.
But I think what's important
about it is, a lot of people
say, well, you're Google.
You're special.
You can do this stuff.
We're different.
And I think what this program
does is say, well, actually,
you can do this stuff anywhere.
It's not just
applicable at Google.
Anyone can get better.
And of course, the four
of us work at Google.
And obviously we know
that Google never
has problems with
developers, pushing features
as fast as possible,
and being incentivized
based on building things
that might not necessarily
be easy to operate.
So Google's obviously
a perfect unicorn.
We never have any
internal issues.
And we are special
and brilliant.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, so you've
got all this research.
It shows some stuff.
What should people do with that?
How do you apply this?
AJA HAMMERLY: I
think you're asking,
when would I ever use this?
Or some variation there of.
BRIAN DORSEY: Or why
bother reading it?
Or what should I
do with this stuff?
NATHEN HARVEY:
Yeah, I would love
to answer that question for you.
But I'd also love to
answer it not yet.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN DORSEY: Wait, what?
AJA HAMMERLY: I don't
think it works that way.
BRIAN DORSEY: Podcast DevOps.
AJA HAMMERLY: Are you trying to
get a second podcast episode?
Is that what you're
trying to do?
NATHEN HARVEY: No, I don't
want to get a second podcast.
Maybe I do.
But I just wanted to
summarize one quick thing
that the research has
shown us over time.
So Jez mentioned
that we're Google so
that probably doesn't apply.
Or you're from Google, that
probably doesn't apply here.
Each year the report looks at
a couple of different things.
But there has been a consistent
thread throughout the years.
And that is looking at things
like lead time and deployment
frequency, which if
you'd say the word DevOps
you might think of
as the dev side.
And then the change fail rate,
so when you push something
to production, how often does
it fail or the time to restore.
And to me both of those feel
more on the operations side.
And so Jez, the
research shows us
that we can either do
one or the other, right?
We can either move fast
or we can be reliable.
Is that right?
JEZ HUMBLE: Absolutely
not, Nathen.
In fact, quite the opposite.
It shows that high
performers do better
at both speed and stability.
It's not in fact a trade-off.
And every year we
get all the data.
And we pop it into a--
you can kind of think
of us as statistical
Harry Potter magic hat
called cluster analysis.
And what cluster
analysis does is
it basically sorts the
participants into groups.
And we don't tell it how
many groups to create
or what those groups
should look like.
But we just say,
here's four variables.
Make groups out of them.
And we always end up with
three or four groups.
And what's interesting is it's
always the case that there's
one group that does really
well on those four metrics--
deploy frequency,
lead time, time
to restore, change fail rate--
and one group that really does
really badly on those four,
and then one or two
groups in between that
are kind of in the
middle and so forth.
So every year we kind
of hold our breath
and we're like, what's
going to pop out this year.
And every year the
same thing pops up,
which is really cool because
it validates that finding,
that actually high performers do
better at speed and stability,
low performers do badly
at speed and stability.
And the practices that help you
get better, if you do it right,
help you get faster and more
secure and more available.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, so tell
me if I'm wrong here.
I think the thing
to do actually is
for people who may
be listening here
know that thinking more
carefully about some
of this DevOps stuff is better,
that you can have both speed
and agility.
They're trying to convince
other people on their teams
or their management folks.
The thing to do is get them to
read this report because it's
actually really readable
and based on research.
Maybe that's the thing.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yes, exactly.
And it's actually
designed in such a way
that you can do that.
So the PDF is quite big.
I think it's over
80 pages this year.
But it's designed in such
a way that if there's
a particular point that you
want to make to your boss,
there's a couple of pages
that you can just print out
and lovingly faux
carelessly put on that desk.
BRIAN DORSEY: This just
happened to end up here.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah, mysterious.
Here's your tea.
And here's a little
coaster to put your tea on.
And oh, look, it's got
these diagrams on it.
So it's definitely designed to
be able to do that, in as much
as people are persuaded by data.
I think in the software
industry we like
to think we're data-oriented.
Often we're not.
We're fashion and
pear-persuaded or influenced.
But in as much as people
can be influenced by data
and research, that's the goal.
NATHEN HARVEY: And so Brian,
coming back to your question
about how do I actually take
this research and put it
to work, you know, Jez
mentioned throwing a copy of it
on your boss's desk.
That is a great first step.
But the other things
that you can do,
if you go to
Cloud.Google.com/DevOps,
in addition to being able to
download the report there,
there's also what we call
a DevOps quick check.
And we will ask you a
series of five questions.
And then we will
show you where do
you fit in terms
of your industry
and in terms of the
research that we've found.
We will put your organization
as a low performer,
a medium performer,
a high performer,
or an elite performer.
And it is across those four key
metrics that we talked about.
And once you
understand that, that
will also give you some insight
onto where you should probably
focus your effort.
And so on that same page,
we have a collection
of key capabilities
that Jez was mentioning,
around technical capabilities,
cultural capabilities,
and so forth.
So really the idea there is
that you focus your resources
on what's currently
holding you back,
identify some constraints,
choose a target, and iterate.
Make those a little bit better.
Get a little bit better
around this capability.
And then reflect.
And do that same thing again.
So this is an iterative process.
The truth is that when you start
your DevOps "transformation"--
and I put that in air quotes--
you're never done.
It is a journey.
You don't wake up one day and
say, well, now we're DevOps.
So what's next?
AJA HAMMERLY: So it's like
everything else in software--
shipping it is not actually
the interesting part.
It's how you keep it going, and
improve it, and iterate on it,
and make it meet the
needs of the humans.
You have to use it
as life goes on.
That's the cool part.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yes.
AJA HAMMERLY: OK.
Is there anything
we missed that you
would like to mention
before we wrap things up?
JEZ HUMBLE: I think the
only thing I want to say
is I just want to pull one
out for Velocity since it
was just recently the last one.
I certainly learned
a ton from Velocity.
It was hugely influential.
Amazing people talked about
amazing things in there.
So thanks to everyone
involved in that conference
over the years.
And rest in peace, Velocity.
AJA HAMMERLY: Hey,
Nathen, how about you?
What did we miss?
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah, I would
say that we talked a little bit
about Velocity.
Again, I share the condolences.
And best wishes for
Velocity and that team.
DevOps Days did celebrate
its 10 year anniversary.
And so that conference
series is still going.
But also, this year the
DevOps Enterprise Summit
celebrated its fifth
year anniversary.
So that's another
great conference.
So I think if you're interested
in learning more about bringing
these practices into
your own organization,
the place to start right now
is Cloud.Google.com/devops.
And then, once you've looked
at some of that research
and gathered some
of that information,
if you're ready to
go to a conference,
find a local DevOps Days,
which you can always
find at DevOpsDays.org.
Or look to the DevOps
Enterprise Summit, which
typically happens twice a year.
JEZ HUMBLE: But, yeah,
first definitely feast
on the yummy DevOps goodness.
NATHEN HARVEY: There's so much,
so much great content there.
AJA HAMMERLY: And this
is why when I found out
I got to interview you two
for the podcast I was excited.
BRIAN DORSEY: I just want
to share with everybody
that what I think was a joke
about not it on the noses
has been in actual practice
through this entire interview.
AJA HAMMERLY: So the last
question we always ask folks--
obviously I'm hoping you
all will get some new fans
being on the podcast.
So if you all find new fans,
where can they find you--
online, in-person,
any of the above?
And I'm going to
make Nathen go first.
NATHEN HARVEY: Awesome.
You can find me online probably
easiest through my Twitter
handle or you could look
at GitHub or what have you.
They're all the same.
It's always Nathen
Harvey everywhere.
But I have to warn you my
father misspelled my name.
So it's N-A-T-H-E-N H-A-R-V-E-Y.
We can put that in the show
notes.
But that's the best
place to find me online.
And then in-person--
well, it really
depends on when this
recording comes out.
By the time it comes
out, you've probably
missed me at DevOps
Days Galway and Next UK.
But in the future
I will definitely
be at DevOps Days conferences.
I also know that Jez
and I will happen
to be together at a conference
in January, the Delivery Conf
that's happening in Seattle.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah.
So I am Jez Humble everywhere
on the internet, all one word
jezhumble, which I know,
J-E-Z and then Humble.
I don't really
get out very much,
which is probably for the best.
But you can see me at
conferences where I am.
And Delivery Conf is probably
the next one, to be honest.
We'll probably all be at Next.
Let's face it.
NATHEN HARVEY: And it's
at Deliveryconf.com.
It's January 21st
and 22nd in Seattle.
AJA HAMMERLY: I promise we will
roll out the wonderful winter
weather for you all.
Cool.
I want to thank you guys.
This was delightful and amusing.
And DevOps is often seen
as a really boring topic.
But everyone I know who works
in this space is awesome.
So I have no idea how
it got that reputation.
But thank you for representing
that this is about people
and this is just about making
everything better for everyone
involved.
JEZ HUMBLE: Thanks.
We work very hard
to make it boring.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah, and
I think a lot of that
has to do with the name.
It's not about dev and ops.
It's all of us.
So you can call it modern.
You can call it digital.
You can call it IT.
Someday we'll stop
using the word
because it'll just be the
way that things get done.
AJA HAMMERLY:
Software and feelings.
OK, well, thanks you all.
NATHEN HARVEY:
Thank you so much.
JEZ HUMBLE: Thank you.
AJA HAMMERLY: So
as you can tell,
Brian and I had a great time
talking to Nathen and Jez
because they are awesome.
And DevOps is just
such a human topic
that it makes for really
easy conversation.
Despite the fact that
everyone kind of thinks of it
as this deeply technical, very
nerdy, very serious space,
I really like the
amount of humanity
that Nathen and Jez
bring to it, which
is why I really like talking
to them about the topic.
And now it is time for
the question of the week.
And Brian has agreed
to be the person who
asks the question this week so
that I can be the person who
gets to answer it.
BRIAN DORSEY: Which
is super appropriate
because I don't know the answer.
And I don't have to play dumb.
I'm actually dumb.
Wrong way to say that, but
I don't know the answer.
So there's this thing
called the Cloud SQL proxy
that it seems like
you need, whenever
you want to talk to Cloud SQL.
Why?
Where does it sit?
What is it for?
I don't understand.
AJA HAMMERLY: So the
first thing to know
is that you don't need it.
It is just the most recommended
way of accessing Cloud SQL.
And to kind of give
an answer to this,
I'm going to use a little
bit of my history in tech.
So back in the day
before I was at Google--
actually before I was even
at the job before I was
at Google--
whenever we needed to
configure our database
to talk to our
application servers
we had to give our
the IP address of the database.
And then we had to
allow the database
to access an IP
address in the range
that we knew our application
servers were going to live in.
And this is fine.
But it is not the most
secure, because it
means that if your
database moves
or if someone starts
spoofing an IP
address or all sorts
of other awful things
that can happen on the internet,
someone could theoretically
break into your database if
they also have the database
password and credentials.
It is much better.
And also it's just not
particularly flexible
because it meant that if we
moved the database around
or if we added servers we
had to redeploy everything.
So what the Cloud
SQL proxy does is
it makes it much easier to
interact with your database
in a secure way.
There is a proxy
application that
either runs on your
local development machine
if you want to do that.
I can't say that
I highly recommend
that for a lot of pre-prod
scenarios like staging
or even development
environments.
That's not a horrible
way to do things.
Or it can run on like
your App Engine cluster.
It's really easy to enable
an App Engine in the app.yaml
or in some of your other compute
variations, GCE, potentially
Cloud Run and others.
And there's just a
little application there.
And all it does is it listens
to all of your database commands
and sends them up to the
other side of the proxy,
which lives on GCP.
It validates that your
credentials are correct.
These are your IAM credentials.
There's a couple different
ways to use them.
But these are the
IAM credentials
that you can control through
either the IAM commands G Cloud
command line or also just
through the Cloud Console.
And then it forwards
them onto the database
so that you don't
actually have to connect
to your database via
IP or your servers
to your database via IP.
And so it basically adds
additional layers of security
and also flexibility by
adding a layer of indirection
between your application
and your database, which
just works better for a
cloud environment, where
things move around.
You might need to
connect applications.
And it also works better because
you can control the access
control in a much
more fine-grained way
because you can know who,
based on the credentials,
not just what IP accessed it.
And I think that is correct.
But there will be a
link in the show notes
so that all you all
can go read the blog
posts or the documentation
page and tell me
the bits I got wrong.
BRIAN DORSEY: Ooh, that
sounds like a challenge.
AJA HAMMERLY: I like
learning things too.
BRIAN DORSEY: So let me see if
I understood this correctly.
So the common production
case is that you
have a copy of this proxy
running on every machine VM
environment.
And the stuff there doesn't
need to know about passwords
or IP addresses.
It just talks to
the local proxy.
And the proxy does authen
in an integrated cloud way.
AJA HAMMERLY: It does need
to know about passwords.
Because every time you're
accessing a database
you have to both
authenticate into the machine
and then also authenticate
into the database.
And this takes care of
authenticating to the machine.
BRIAN DORSEY: Got it.
AJA HAMMERLY:
Basically verifying
who can access the
machine-- but you still need
to have your valid
password or account
to access the database because
your database account controls
your permissions for the
data in the database.
So databases contain very
important information.
And we should secure
them carefully.
BRIAN DORSEY: No kidding.
Somebody is going
to disagree with me,
but this sounds a little
bit like two-factor auth
for a database
connection in a way.
Cool.
Thank you for that.
I learned a lot.
And I hope everyone
else did too.
This is the section where
we talk about where people
are going to be and lead on.
Where are you going to be, Aja?
AJA HAMMERLY: It's
the end of the year.
I'm going to be at home drinking
tea and playing with codes.
BRIAN DORSEY: Love it.
This is going to be a
really easy and short one
because same is true for me--
tea, and playing with
tech, and maybe some games.
But I'm trying to learn about
LoRa radio communication,
and silliness with like how
we know you like things.
So we'll see what
happens there on my end.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, my
tech's not that cool.
I am still working on my
Cloud Functions application
to keep my cat in the house.
I am hoping that I will get a
couple more hours to finish it
off so that I can write the
blog post showing how you
can use Cloud Functions and
Cloud Tasks to hit an HTTP
endpoint.
It's actually a
reasonable business case,
but I'm using it to
keep my cat in the house
because my cat can open doors.
BRIAN DORSEY: This is amazing.
Wait, have you talked about
this on the podcast before?
Like we can't just
end without you--
AJA HAMMERLY: I
don't think I have.
I don't think I have.
BRIAN DORSEY: So how did you
get from HTTP over to doorknobs?
AJA HAMMERLY: Smart house.
There's an HTTP
endpoint that I can
use to lock the doors for my
house via authentication means.
There's actually multiple
layers of indirection there.
But just a short version
is, I hit a specific HTTP
endpoint with
specific credentials
and it locks the doors.
And then I can trigger that.
It also triggers an event
when the doors unlock.
So you then use Cloud Tasks
to add a timer to time out.
And while this particular use
case is completely ridiculous,
there are a lot of
use cases in business
where an event happens that
you can use to trigger a Cloud
Function, and then you want
to some time later maybe send
a sign up email or
send a reminder email
or something like that.
Or maybe not even
an email, maybe you
want to go hit a Slack endpoint
or something like that,
but you want to
do it on a delay.
And there is a surprisingly
large number of business cases
that are like that.
I'm just happening to use a
particularly hilarious one
to motivate my application.
BRIAN DORSEY: That is brilliant.
AJA HAMMERLY: And yes,
for everyone listening,
there is a much
better way to do this.
I wanted to play
with Cloud Functions.
BRIAN DORSEY: That is awesome.
Fantastic.
Thank you.
Have an awesome holiday
playing with that.
And I hope everybody
had a great podcast
and has a good rest of the month
and time, holidays and stuff.
[MUSIC PLAYING]